yo what's up this is Nelly Chopper I'm
here again always this is home for me
check me out on the bootleg cab podcast
I need everybody to come through let's
do it
bootleg cab show special guest in here
my bro analy Chopper always home yes
it's home right here yeah a few times
appreciate you coming through man always
uh explain the new jewelry here I
haven't seen this necklace yet this
looks very uh holistic uh this is simply
me meditating in rose gold that's you
yeah
it's a it's one of my favorite pieces
that shit's fire
um yeah meditation man I mean you know I
feel like uh when I first started to
record interviews out of here you came
on pretty early
and I feel like that was kind of like
one of the first interviews where you
like kind of revealed this other side of
yourself that you were discovering like
the more spiritual uh natural some of
the diet stuff you're doing like are you
still like on that path in terms of like
take taking care of what you're putting
in your body yeah even more stronger now
I don't talk about it as much as I feel
like because I kind of broke the ground
with it already yeah but it's like I'm
even more stronger uh recently I just
tweeted like that I've been on a been on
like a type of fast to where I'm only
eating raw vegetables and fruits and
I've been doing that for like two months
no sex
um
a lot of teas a lot of herbs a lot of
sunlight meditation prayer so it's been
it's been even stronger hyphen now
because I know more right you know so
two months straight just veggies and
fruits and no cooked Foods nothing no
beating no sex no sex wow yeah is that
hard
um I'm getting to the point to where my
discipline is starting to get extremely
sharp it's kind of like um it's a goal
I'm working towards so I feel like when
you put intentions over what the fastest
Ford it kind of helps you stay grounded
and not want to get off schedule because
if you're really trying to work towards
something like you genuinely want that
change you would be disciplined enough
to stay on that course how do you feel
like because a lot of people talk about
those raw diets no cooked food does it
like do you feel the difference man you
feel amazing like you feel you feel so
close to the inner child like how you
felt before you have responsibilities
you know
um if I could be just happy all day and
smiling all day I could be at that point
but I still have to work so I can't
really do it but I still feel like a
child just a child that's working you
know well look to be fair man we've seen
you kind of grow up in front of our eyes
for so did like you're I mean I think we
forget how young you are and I think the
first time you and I met you might have
been 17 something like that yeah but
like when you really first popped and
like that I remember when you you made
that big deal to like do the United
Masters move instead of going major that
was a big deal for the industry because
it was kind of like one of the first
artists at the time you probably could
have signed anywhere and you decided to
stay independent but you were like 16 at
the time yeah for sure so you know it's
just it's been dope to watch your growth
man because most people get lost in the
sauce at your age bro I always do and
they get wrapped up in that negative
[ __ ] but you've like grown into like a
grown ass man bro in front of our eyes
man appreciate that I feel like at a
point in my career I was kind of wrapped
into it for sure but he was on IG live a
while kid bruh somebody got to get this
guy yeah it had to take
um realization of a lot of things to
know um what God put me in this position
for what was the plan originally before
I even blew up you know once I got back
to that plan everything's been
beautiful for me now what was was there
a moment in time or something like a
specific action that happened that kind
of made you realize like you got to kind
of change your trajectory as a as a man
my thoughts you know my thoughts was
getting very intrusive on like oh I'd be
better off if I wasn't here you know and
once they got to those type of thoughts
I was like okay something I need to
change because I'm not suicidal but I
know like
if I'm thinking like that it can get to
that point so I took I took heed of it
and I said a real strong prayer that
night and nobody can ever tell me prayer
doesn't work and then the next day I
found meditation and then within that I
changed my diet then within that I
changed the people I was hanging around
and with that net I stopped doing drugs
like it was a lot of things that came
after me just pouring love into myself
and care so what happened was
essentially you just kind of had the
thought process of like maybe things
would be better if I just wasn't here
not necessarily suicidal but just the
fact that that thought started to creep
into your your mind yeah and I just you
know it was getting to that point so I
knew like I knew things had to give I
knew things had to change and all I was
willing to do it I was willing to go to
the extra strength to see could I get
myself back on course before I even
visited something that could have taken
myself away you know what um what drugs
were you doing at the time really just
we
um I was smoking it was around
quarantine what's really happening and I
felt I was like in my lows it was a lot
going on smoking a lot of weed smoking
too much I was overly smoking probably
like two three backwood packs a day 3.5
every wood Jesus
in every wood yeah so I was over smoking
um
it was just and I used to do Percocets
and stuff I feel like that had a effect
on me too but I wasn't on perks like
that um as far as when I was smoking a
lot I had kind of tuned toned it down a
little bit
but um I was just on I was just home
because you know
first of all that's dope that you I
think it's dope when people share that
[ __ ] because a lot of people are dealing
with I think weed is great I love weed
but I also think it can be uh
counterintuitive to being you know
active in your life can make you very
relaxed lazy you know so I think it's
dope to share that and then even like
the Percocet thing like [ __ ] man
nowadays these kids are like so yeah I'm
at the right time yeah because because
the now it's the fentanyl you got to
worry about you know what I mean I feel
like I got off them the right time
because you know fentanyl just got
popular like three years ago right
really two and a half years ago and
that's like around the time I stopped I
stopped like matter of fact that they um
they said juice world had passed I had
popped my last one and that was my last
one and ever since then I never bought
one was that like uh when you saw him
him pass away was that uh Catalyst for
you to stop doing them it was more so a
respect thing because you know the story
of how he passed away he swallowed out
perks I was kind of like I was like
looking at it like that didn't really
make sense but in the same sense I was
like out of respecter bro I'ma still
never pop one again just in case if that
was the case
um world may never know but I know there
was spark you need to stop what up y'all
we gotta stop the interview real quick
tell you about our partners at mybookie
man look it's so much to gamble on right
now we got World Cup soccer we got bowl
games coming up NBA basketball uh of
course NFL man we're getting into the
playoffs in a few weeks well in like six
weeks or something like that uh with
that being said let's win some money all
right go to my bookie right now sign up
with that promo code bootleg and they
will match your deposit up to a thousand
dollars that's free money to gamble with
that's free money what are we talking
about my bookie uh let's talk about the
props you could bet on all kinds of
player props NBA points uh well Giannis
win the MVP you can do Futures on the
awards season for the NBA uh so much
going on you could also still bet on the
NFL mvprs as well there's just so much
ways to get money on my bookie but
what's most important is that they're
giving you free money you sign up at my
bookie right now you use the promo code
bootleg and they won't match your first
deposit up to a thousand dollars that's
right free money what are we doing head
over there put in some bets and let's
try to win some [ __ ] money together
all right my bookie use the promo code
bootleg let's get back to the interview
you guys uh met uh how was he as a guy I
mean I was cool I had a freestyle on my
show once and I was blown away because
he wrapped for like 15 minutes straight
yo that's really this I feel like this
is the story of juice like it was a
[ __ ] Master Class rapper crazy and
like didn't even do that on his albums
really but like he could wrap circles
around everybody like off the top of his
head man I remember the first tour I
went on and there was a juice World Tour
ski mask slump God and then I was like
the opener to a lot of the shows lots of
mosh Pits on that tour a whole lot of
them
um
first time meeting them the first thing
he said to me was like yo my favorite
gun at kale Tech what's yours and I was
like damn you know what's up for nothing
like I know after that I just kind of
took a liking them to him because I knew
he was different you know I said I told
him I like draco's and then after that
we was just cool and he wrapped for like
30 minutes straight like 30 minutes I
was just mesmerized I was sitting down
looking at him like yo he not stopping
like he was it was put on another beat
like after he's already been eight
minutes in on one beat telling him to
replay it keep replaying it over I was
like yo that [ __ ] machine it's pretty
historical tour to be a part of man it
was beautiful
um a lot of people I met along until I
think like um cold Bennett met a lot of
people sitting down a great foundation
for myself
um it was a beautiful tour it was
beautiful and then it was crazy um when
it came for me to have my own tour this
year
um I had nle tour in America and I sold
out like 90 of my dates like
congratulations and it was huge for me
because I felt like like juice like and
then I had people that was coming the
tour that was open enough for me and I
was looking at them as like me yeah
hoping like four years y'all have your
own [ __ ] going like you know what I mean
that's dope man then I went to Europe
and Canada all in this same year and I
sold out Europe completely sold out
Canada like 90 of that as well you know
it was just beautiful so I felt like I
felt like the universe was bringing you
know great blessings upon me and like
versus where I was when I was 16 was
just looking at it how was Europe like
what was the craziest city in Europe you
guys went to craziest City I gotta go
with Tel Aviv like it was banging on the
street in Israel right yeah it was
banging on the Sprinter when we were
leaving
um it was just a beautiful experience
right a very beautiful experience to see
a lot of my fans Copenhagen who was
crazy in Copenhagen
um Amsterdam I went to the red light
district I got to say that everything
did you participate in a red light
district or were you seeming retenting
at the time no I've participated really
yeah it was the experience I had to
first time paying for [ __ ] how much was
it how much was it like 150 Buck 50 huh
Buck 50. nice bad I was like damn that's
great I heard like I've never been and I
won't go because I'm married obviously
but I've heard like certain sections of
the red light district like if you like
Latin women there's like a Latin woman
section
so so it's it's it's all that people say
it is huh yeah it's beautiful it was
crazy so when you pay the 150 do they
give you a condom yeah they give you a
condom and um you come in this little
room it kind of smell like sex in more
than one way you come in the little room
yeah
smell like ass like people been [ __ ]
like people been in there beating
[ __ ] cheeks yeah but um it was an
experience man it was pretty cheap yeah
it is right surprised you didn't do the
twofer man I was I was I wanted the
double it was crazy I wanted like two of
them but um one of them at the top that
was acting real bougie so I was like I'm
gonna spend my money with you so I went
to the hub did they know who you were
um I don't think so that's that's
probably good yeah it was like no man I
was awesome that would have charged me
way more of course that hit you with the
rapper tax on me
that's fire so uh were you able to like
uh participate did you go to like any of
the weed cafes and [ __ ] over there oh
yeah I went to them they had like um
they had like weed cafes I think CJ
didn't you go to some we went to yeah we
went it was like a coffee weed shop it
was crazy I bet you CJ had a good
[ __ ] time yeah he had a great time I
bet he did I ain't I ain't even smoke
you know what I think I did I hit a
blunt with them that day I think I hit a
blown with them aren't mushrooms over
there legal too I have no clue I don't
think so I don't know might be
Amsterdam's a wild place man shout out
to Amsterdam that's a noun shout out to
it
I would never experience the red light
district but
I'm living vicarious three uh
vicariously through you my friend
um yo you're single now right I'm single
all the way okay I remember when you
broke up with your girl you definitely
sparked a debate we talked about it on
the radio show do you feel like
humans in general are meant to be with
people forever no okay
elaborate I already knew what she was
about to say elaborate because that was
I mean I I kind of appreciated like your
uh transparency in that situation it
didn't get messy you were just very much
like hey look I had a discussion and an
agreement with my lady I love her
obviously but when that agreement
started to get kind of you know violated
or whatever like you know it's not like
you didn't tell her about it you know
what I'm saying I mean I feel like
everybody's had a survey Purpose with
whatever that is right on life
life is a is a journey first and
foremost and um along that Journey
everything is temporary nothing is
permanent in life you know what I'm
saying not one thing is one of them
things that's just gonna last forever
right that's permanent but death to the
physical but even after the physical
death if you're transformed into
something else because energy doesn't
die right so nothing is ever permanent
so I feel like a lot of people just come
in my life to to serve some type purpose
for me to learn something and all right
once I learn it it's ready to go on the
next Journey The Next Step what's next I
don't I don't ever feel I have somebody
in my life that's just always going to
be there because in the same sense like
it's just it's just over a period of
time things turn sour and things turn
sour because it's not meant to be held
on to Forever it's okay we did this we
did this okay now I feel like it's time
for me to let go and you to grow and for
me to let go and I I can grow so I can
get whatever
at this time from each other and now we
kind of take what we took from the
relationship and move on yeah move on
yeah like that's that's how it would be
you know that's a part of Detachment
people people are missing Detachment in
everyday life
um you got to be able to detach from
things because if you don't it can hurt
you in the long run you know what I'm
saying would you
pretty much say that it'd be difficult
to Envision yourself ever being married
um I don't I don't see myself being
married not really
um marriage is a beautiful thing but um
I don't see myself being married because
every married couple I talked to they're
not happy like everyone
um it depends like how long they've been
married but anybody I've talked to
that's like five years and over I asked
them about marriage they were like yeah
it's cool but don't do it like that's
the that's every married couple so like
I've just learned from that experience
I'm like I'm I'm not would you ever pull
the AC on and have like you know the
police little seven or eight wives just
you know that's what I like to have a
house full of wives yeah I mean it's a
village you know it'll help you build
what you're trying to accomplish like if
you have a lot of women that's around to
help you build what you're trying to con
accomplish you don't have attachment
issues a lot of things you're gonna be
like another Nick Cannon in 10 years I
love kids I feel like my we hear the
population though listen I got a feeling
in 10 years every three weeks we're
gonna see Emily chop is expecting a new
baby and before we know it you're gonna
have 30 kids and that's a beautiful
it'll see look this is a beautiful thing
and and you're gonna be miserable
because you're gonna have to babysit 28
of them
yo you know if you have over 10 to 12
kids you don't have to pay child support
that's a dub really yeah if you have if
you have over 10 to 12 kids you don't
have to in certain cities I'm not sure
that's true for any of them in certain
in certain cities it's true if it's with
one girl maybe I think it's different
women so if you have 10 kids with 10
women they're all they're 10 women are
[ __ ] from getting child support off
you oh yeah I mean but I might be wrong
but if you're looking for someone to
have 10 kids and not be there for them
yeah for sure yeah that's all for sure
you got to take care of them but you
know I think that's the thing have you
met Nick Cannon yeah yeah my guy I've
been wilding out everything with them
you guys should have a little like uh I
feel like you guys are you know you know
you know who else I know I I I I I
really would love if one day you and
Kevin Gates sat down and did a podcast I
knew he was gonna say that if you and
Kevin Gates could just sit down for
three hours and then we just film the
conversation and you guys trade like
semen retention [ __ ] tips and [ __ ]
I'm like you guys are very
[ __ ] spiritually woke on another
level yeah for sure
and he'd be working out and [ __ ] now
yeah he's good he could do he always
check in from checking on me time to
time what's up little brother and you
know keep your foot on that neck he um
he really admires me I think he looks at
me as a as if I'm him you know yo what
happens boo like Kev gotta interrupt the
interview shout out to our good friends
at Blue chew it is cuffing season it's
getting cold as a [ __ ] outside right
now and uh you could definitely use a
little extra
um fellas all right blue chew will have
your dick harder than goddamn
trigonometry all right so if if you
really really you know trying to get
your dick game right trying to make sure
your performance is at an all-time high
go to Bluetooth right now bluetooth.com
use the promo code bootleg they're gonna
give you a month supply for free that's
right a whole month for free
bluetooth.com use that promo code
bootleg get your first month for free my
friend Adam Wade could use some
Bluetooth that's for sure there he is so
uh this is what it is man it's got the
same active ingredients as Viagra and
Cialis in a chewable pill form it gets
delivered right to your doorstep in
discrete packaging you don't have to go
to the doctor to get Bluetooth it's all
online all right and you get your first
month for free try it out and then thank
me later bluetooth.com promo code
bootleg plus they just dropped the new
blue chew mint chewable which has the
same active ingredients as Levitra and
that should have you [ __ ] rocked up
and stocked up bud all right so one more
time bluetooth.com use that promo code
bootleg get your first month for free
let's get back to the interview how you
know because I I think about Memphis and
I think about
um you know when you from the time you
first came in obviously there was CMG
and Dolph and yourself and key Glock but
now it's like Memphis is truly at the
floor of a hip-hop it's like a
Powerhouse everyone's stealing y'all
slang everyone's using y'all's producers
just is what it is Memphis got the [ __ ]
sewed up right now shout out to glorilla
shout out to him hey people that aren't
from Memphis are even saying mersik
instead of music
you know
um but with that being said
there's always been a high level of
negativity associated with the scene
there and I feel like
at least with the bigger guys it feels
like it's getting past that like
um how did you break through like not
kind of getting wrapped up in a lot of
the Memphis politics
um just being able to want to spark
change you know
um lead by example show something
different I didn't I always didn't want
to be the norm I know God created me to
blaze a trail of my own or create a land
for other people
um to give other people options
um so coming up I knew like
I've I looked up to Gotti Dove because I
feel like those were the two biggest at
the city growing up of course so with
that being said I took heed of stuff
they done golf had paper out yep got it
had CMG and I looked at it as if
I would never want to sign to these guys
but I would want to create my own Empire
like how they did it and um I feel like
this one I'm in the works are doing
um just giving that other route that
other option to the people from the city
and um I feel like I'm doing damn good
doing it you know I got four artists I
got a producer that's crazy that's
getting a lot of a lot of blessed
placements right now so you know what
I'm saying
it's a beautiful journey and probably 10
10 years from now five years from now
maybe even three in their league can be
one of those big Powerhouse labels
that's out of Memphis Tennessee I see it
happening too man
um how big of a loss just being a kid
from Memphis was losing Dolph man
um just a simple fact of just a person
that led away you know a person that
that sparked inspiration upon me sparked
inspiration Upon A lot of people from
his hood his City and then he touched a
lot of other all the other 50 other
states you know I'm saying plus the
global field you know of what he did and
what he came about was just his label so
it was a loss and was crazy I tell
people how intuitive and how like
prophetic I'd be top tapped into the man
like the day the day the morning of when
he passed he died before I woke up so I
was still asleep but man I had this
dream of dogs Dolphins I was in the
water with dolphins and they were just
swimming with me and when I when I woke
up I was like what the [ __ ] was that
dream man and like I looked at my phone
and that was the first thing I saw so it
was like that death sparked a wave of
energy across the whole world so you
knew how how powerful he was and what he
built so I always looked up to it that
stuff man
um the first I would I would say the
last time you were up here uh at the
show was maybe like a year ago and I
don't think you would really try trooms
yet and I gave you some shrooms
you say you've you've had some pretty
serious trips yeah talk about some of
the crazier trips you've had on
psilocybin so far man so my recent trip
I was just saying um not too long ago
was um I was literally laying in Miami I
was in Miami and I was I was grounded
with Earth and I I just laid down and um
took a few shrooms like a handful of
them and um
so when I speak on certain out-of-body
experiences you got to speak on it it's
like a spiritual sense because it's way
beyond the physical but in a spiritual
sense I was laying down and it's like
the top of my head opened up so of
course it didn't open up physically
right it opened up in a spiritual sense
um it opened up and then like my hair in
the spiritual sense it rolls up and
connected like a dread and formed one
dread real strong right so I felt my
hair was like my antenna that kept me
grounded between my body and where I was
going in the spiritual realm so my hair
I felt it it was like like a strong one
dread just keeping me attached to my
body as I went to where I went to and um
I know for a fact it was my son that
came and took me on that Journey because
my son RP told him he he got miscarried
his name's seven so um my son pretty
much took me on a journey to a woman's
womb I don't know if it was the womb I
was president or if it was the womb that
he was president in before he miscarried
so I was in a womb and um
I felt the most unconditional loving
soothing and just
beautiful type of feeling it wasn't
nothing I saw it was more so of what I
felt and the feeling was so beautiful
after I got back to Consciousness on a
3D level when I got up I cried and it
was so beautiful because
within that process I realized how
important women are within that process
I realized how important a healthy
pregnancy is I realized um that God is
literally forming you in that stomach
and literally pouring every sense of
Personality Talent
um everything until you while you're in
that room
um and fourthly I realized the heaven
state that was Heaven I feel like I felt
the presence of God and nothing mattered
in that space like nothing like if I
could stay there forever I would stay
there it was that beautiful you know wow
would you suggest other people trying
shrooms because I feel like you wouldn't
suggest other people I wouldn't suggest
everyone because they I feel like
they'll take too much at one time and
just go on a trip but I do suggest if
people want to get into it to start off
with a very very small adult overdose
yeah micro dosing to it and then going
along that Journey you got to get your
feet wet which you gotta you can't just
dive all the way in because then you're
you're freak out yeah for sure but I do
recommend people to start with
meditation first because I started with
meditation and then everything started
to open up for me so if you're wanting
to take shrooms or psychedelics whatever
I say start with meditation and being
able to get to a certain level of
Consciousness with just your breath
first and then implement the things that
God said for you hey what up y'all we
gotta stop the interview real quick to
tell you about our folks at hardean Las
Vegas you see them right there you know
I mean shout out to hard D Man shout out
to everybody over there it's the illest
dispensary in the world number one they
got the craziest selection of weed
you'll ever go to when you're in Las
Vegas there's only one place to go
that's hard in you pull up you say hey I
heard about this place on the bootleg
cat podcast and they're gonna get you
hooked up with some [ __ ] weed all
right so go to Jardin Las Vegas right
now if you're in the city of uh sin or
you're going make sure you uh you know
put it put together a little hour off to
the side to make sure you go get your
nice [ __ ] Harding bag full of uh just
a premium weed all right and and not
only that you got to shoot them a follow
Harding underscore Las Vegas I want to
shout them out though because Harding
smells the best the dispensary is just
it's not only the best dispensary in the
world it's the best smelling dispensary
in the world and look now the bootleg
kit podcast smells like Jardin because I
have the Jardine signature scent candle
you could have one too you could go to
[ __ ] Hardy in Las Vegas just saying
also make sure you follow them online
Harding underscore Las Vegas that is
important you have to follow them
because there's some [ __ ] accounts
out there we appreciate hard Dean when
you're in Vegas pull up go get you some
smoke go get you some edibles go get you
some [ __ ] carts whatever it is they
got it and they got it at the highest
quality it's the only place I'm smoking
from that's Hardy in Las Vegas let's get
back to the interview I think people
also over over think what meditation is
right because I think like
does it have to be like like explain
kind of like how you meditate on a
day-to-day basis but I'd say I mean I
can meditate whenever throughout the day
it's just simple
breeding out through the mouth and it's
just simply focusing on that like just
keep focusing on it and the more you
focus on on that that sense of breeding
the deeper you get and the more in
Rhythm you get with Earth
um a lot of people can never really get
a rhythm because they never took a deep
breath they never really you know
some people bring breathe wrong too some
people bring breathe in through their
mouth and out through their nose my
French Bulldog breathe is wrong he
doesn't have a choice though so um yeah
to be able to just be able to get your
breathing right focus on your breathing
and on deep meditations I do those a lot
like if I'm about to lay down
um and I just lay down and focus on my
breathing and people say I think about
this I think about that which is count
how many seconds it took for you to
inhale and count how many seconds it
took for your exhale and that'll help
you focus on your breathing because your
mind is now counting have you done Yoga
Yoga yeah I've done yoga how's that
um it's beautiful I don't do it too much
but um it's for sure like one of those
things that's needed to try and my wife
does hot yoga and I always ask her like
how many people are in the room because
I had like 20 I'm like what if someone
farts in them
I just rather do it at the crib alone
you know what I mean but it's crazy
um you got this new record with two
Raiders going crazy
um I think this is like one of your
biggest records at least on Rhythm radio
that you've had yeah for sure for sure
talk about I mean you've been working
man so what you I'm sure you got a lot
of [ __ ] in the chamber what are you
sitting on man I'm sitting on album on
the way I'm sitting on the album for
sure top of the Year okay probably
around February Cottonwood too but even
after that I'm sitting on like seven to
ten more albums Jesus without even
having to record [ __ ] like that's how
much music I have and how much I've been
sewing like how much I've been working
and um that was time to reap you know
who's on the album besides the true bear
oh so I have I'm still getting some
features features together but I know
for certain we got Rick Ross on there
um
Friday Friday no no Friday Friday is on
the album next see I got like yeah okay
so for sure Kevin Gates right now and um
I feel like a lot of the features I'm
still getting them together so I can't
say it yeah for sure those are dope yeah
yeah
do you feel like uh like you engaged to
like Kindred Spirits kind of me like we
like trying to like um like we kind of
like the same like you're just like a
younger like I can feel it in a sense he
he a little bit more out there with it
oh he's out there I was gonna say have
you gotten to the point of wokeness
where you can touch a car battery and
start a car no no dude you saw that
story you told him like yeah he's like
yo I pulled over on the side of the road
and I just touched this lady's battery
and the car started but the energy of
your the energy of your hands the energy
of you and your intent for sure who can
do things like that so you think that's
possible for sure really it's people
that can move water and move waves
without touching it really um I'll be
controlling air sometimes like they've
been around me out there or hair like
air like being like outside that Memphis
accent
so how do you control the air explain
um just simple breathing and just I
really don't know when you just control
the air just like so I can make it grow
to be stronger in the presence down man
like the air can be stronger or I can
make it calm really yeah so would you
say kind of like Storm from the X-Men
um I don't know I don't know do you
think you could make it rain
um I made it rain harder than what it
was raining before which is what I was
doing wow
or I mean yeah I mean there's two ways
of making it rain I mean you did make it
rain at the red red light district right
what's the name of the album you said
Cottonwood too Cottonwood too wow second
go around matter of fact the Cottonwood
the first Cottonwood was around the time
you first met us and this coming back
forward Circle to me um I feel like on
that project I didn't put my best so
this time I want to put the best music I
have on there for um
my my current self yeah so um hey this
time it's gonna be even better do you
feel like
um your fans are also kind of like
evolving with you in terms of like you
know because I think what's dope is like
you are one of the few young artists who
are like really putting out positive
messages to their fans you know what I'm
saying are you seeing the fans pick up
on some of the [ __ ] you're you're trying
to help them with um to begin the
beginning of it it wasn't really too
hipped on it was like what are you
talking when they were calling you know
yeah they was like what what you know I
feel like through the process of that I
started to understand it and started to
realize the message I was providing was
like unlike any other message that was
out there and I guess people started to
take heed of it and um I've been
changing a lot of lives like a ton of
lives on people hit me every day where
it is simple depression anxiety or even
health issues they had I've helped
reverse them so with just me being vocal
or with people just using products I've
promoted so you know it's crazy hey we
got stop the interview to tell you about
our family at odd sucks that's right the
most comfortable socks in the
[ __ ] world go to
oddsoxofficial.com right now use that
promo code bootleg and you'll save 20
off Christmas time is it coming and let
me tell you something their Black Friday
sale if you're watching this before
Black Friday you might be watching it
after Black Friday but if Black Friday
hasn't came yet just like Cyrus hasn't
came yet it's been a while he's on a
drought guess what oddsoxofficial.com
promo code bootleg 20 off plus whatever
the [ __ ] else is going on with their
Black Friday sale and let me tell you
they got some new licenses we got to
talk about boys
my particular favorites
one of the greatest shows of all time
they got the Beavis and butt heads you
know what I mean and this is really a
big deal
The Big Lebowski that's right the
greatest movie to ever exist
and shout out to all you rappers and
people who be pouring your lean into
this [ __ ] some Mountain Dew Baja
Blast socks
Casino great [ __ ] movie you know what
I mean these are pretty fly Bubblicious
yeah that's right a little Bubblicious
and this is the big one
big deal here
we got Coca-Cola socks baby that's right
Coke's on board
Coke is on board yeah I mean we get to
put the coke hat on
this hat doesn't work for me does it
doesn't work for me anyway you could get
you this hat though hey Cyrus take a
Coke hat there you go go to
oddsoxofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg right now save 20 off and go
purge their website for Black Friday get
gifts for your family your [ __ ]
family will love you if you buy them the
most comfortable socks in the world it's
that simple or you could buy them some
[ __ ] [ __ ] socks you could go buy
him some garbage ass [ __ ] ethica or
some [ __ ] ass [ __ ] Nike socks
[ __ ] them get Odd Socks let's get back
to the interview would you say um for
anyone who's watching this right who
just wants to be healthier
maybe it's the raw fruits and veggies
diet but like what would you kind of
suggest someone's diet bee that just
kind of wants to lose weight or just get
their health together they've been
eating [ __ ] hot Cheetos and ramen
noodles and all kinds of [ __ ] and
Jack in the Box there's another one
thing it's always I say a lifestyle
change of course gotta change everything
like because I mean even the last time I
saw you you had like your own special
bottled water that was like there's no I
mean yeah you had some [ __ ] woke ass
water bro man you gotta change your
whole lifestyle though that's that's
really the thing um it's it's never like
a herb they can do it it's never like
one meal they can do it it's a full
lifestyle it comes from dietary
um the way that you live on a day-to-day
basis it's all about process of
elimination eliminating the bad and
outwearing it with the good and just
moving forth with that it's a lifestyle
change what is the one um terrible food
that was very bad for you but you miss
um anything that's of the Jamaican
culture jerk chicken
um curry goat
um Aki with sawfish
um because you know my mom and my
grandmother they're Jamaican so there
was a lot of things I missed missed but
I don't crave it it's never like I'm
gonna go back to it but because I can't
make it in a vegan way uh walk me
through your
supplement daily routine like when you
wake up what vitamins are you taking
you're doing CMOS every day like what
are you what are you doing everyday
vitamin supplement wise just to kind of
so I'm I'm having herbs I'm waking up I
I take like four different
four different um
four different bottle capsules okay and
I take three capsules and I I don't take
the couch so I just pour it into powder
form and drink it with my water so it's
like 12 capsules I have on a wake up
just in my water which consists of light
herbs black walnut contrivo sea moss
um things of that nature but it's a it's
a lot of herbs guaco has a pH of like
12. so a lot of alkaline herbs and then
um I go into droppers like I have like
certain drops and then I go into herbal
teas and this is all before I probably
consume fruit or vegetables and then I
go into my fruits my vegetables and then
I drink
um water it's like very very like strict
and healthy and it's like nothing this
just it's just an unhealthy sense when
are you gonna break the drought what
drought I mean sex drop oh I'm like
um minutes of self and post drought
let's be clear too yeah I mean if it
comes to me yeah if it feels right to do
it
um and even then I'ma still hold back if
you do you not even watch the uh the
prawn like are you like off of the Hub
as well
um like I'm out the hood but are you not
manually stimulating
um if I do do it I'll hold back so like
it wouldn't really count because like
give yourself you give yourself
pleasure yeah for sure but like not all
the way yeah not all the way that's fine
not to the point to where I release
because I gotta keep that energy Loops
you have a serious level of self-control
for sure that I commend highly sir you
got to when I feel like that's one of
the main reasons why God is gonna make
me one of the biggest in the world
because why would he give it to someone
that's not in control of their life I'm
gonna ask you because I think that
there's a difference between between
believing in God and being quote unquote
like religious I'm not religious no way
shape or form right no way I I just feel
like it's I feel like a lot of things
are gangs I feel like it's just a game
no religion is a man-made gang it's a
great way to control poor people over
the history of our planet and but but I
don't take away from it because some
people some people find positivity into
it or it keeps some people out of
trouble it's whatever works for you
whatever makes God real or spark God
within yourself that's what it is
because honest the honest to God truth
is prayer meditation and just faith is
all you need in life because God sits
right here every day he's with you every
day he's within you he gives you free
will to be a reflection or another a
branch of him he's like the tree and
you're the branch so that makes you a
God as well as if he's the prime Creator
right also a Creator the same way I can
write a piece of paper down and draw a
picture of you I've created something
right so I'm a Creator right with all
gods which is not the big G so remember
said man I appreciate your time bro
with two on the way top of the Year top
of the year like February
um
let's not have 30 kids
40. I got you for sure
your mom's gonna kill me
appreciate you man always brother always
a pleasure yes sir